tehát mint itt úgy van van egy olyan
mondás hogy ha egy vagyunk egy egy
szobában van két zsidó akkor van három
vélemény van egy ilyen mondás ezt a
székelyekre is mondják hogy
h vagy magyarokra tehát ez a ez a balhés
része megvan a politikának is tehát
hogyha megnézel egy parlamenti ülést
például izraelbe akkor akkor sokkal
nagyobb balhékat sokkal nagyobb
gordibálásokat fogsz látni még hogy nem
verekednek tehát hogy hogy sokkal jobban
nekimennek egy ak a politikusok
és ugyan ugye e a társadalomban is
megvan hogyha ha ha valamit csinál
miniszterelnök az teljesen mindegy hogy
netányáu vagy nem
hogyha a népnek nem tetszik itt egy
kettőre 10 20 30 4000 ember megy
kitüntetni tehát itt nem itt nem várak
sokat tehát hogy ahogy visszatérnék az
előző mondanivalómra hogy romániában
például egy probléma hogy a nép nagyon
nagyon sokat tűr tehát hogy
csinál néha egy ilyen rendszerváltást és
akkor utána el egy 30-40 év minden jól
van és
akkor érted amit mondok tehát hogy
hogy igazából a a a román társadalom
akkor megy ki az utcára amikor már éhes
az gond